hustle Khan's pretty cool yeah my name
is Adam Draper I'm founding a founder
and managing director of boost VC and
I'm gonna talk to you about fundraising
how many people sorry these lights I
can't really see everyone but how many
people are I have started a business and
how many people have actually gone
through the fundraising process okay so
less of you so this is going to be
relevant to most of you
that's great and it'll be relevant to
all the people who have actually raised
their hands so my name is Adam Draper
I'm a fourth generation venture
capitalist I'm a pounder of I founded a
company called expert financial in 2009
I found a boost VC in 2012 from
basically I help entrepreneurs not make
the mistakes I made with expert
financial and then I've invested in
about 130 companies at this point
collectively they've raised about 300
million dollars and I see about 1,200
pitches every year so I've also it's not
up here been probably because it wasn't
relevant but I was on Nickelodeon at one
point
nailed it
but uh so I'm basically all this means
is my ancestors raised money and helped
people raise money I've raised money for
different things and I really enjoy
helping entrepreneurs get better at what
they do so today's talk I'm I have ten
minutes to tell you all I know about
fundraising which I it could be a longer
conversation but I'm gonna give you
about seven points that I believe might
help in the fundraising process it's
more like concepts to wrap your head
around when you're going through the
process my first my first piece of
advice is fundraising is very difficult
it took Christopher Columbus seven years
to raise money from Queen Isabella in
order to travel across the ocean in
order to find India and he failed
epically at that and he found I was
pictured like Christopher Columbus like
going back and saying like oh man I
didn't find India but fundraise really
difficult with what what fundraising is
incredibly difficult I when I was
pitching to raise money for boost I
emailed 3,000 people I met with 350 of
those investors 3,000 investors met with
350 and I ended up with over about 35
investors and so it was about 10 percent
decline but and it took 12 months to do
this so it was at 12 months in November
2013 to November 2014 I was raising and
that's really really hard it's mentally
trying it so yes 35 people said yes to
me that means that 315 people said no
and dealing with that is a really really
difficult thing every day and so I so
really just start if you're going
through that process just know going
into it that's going to be really
difficult and make sure that you're
ready for the trying trials and
tribulations you're going to be going
through ok number two once you've
wrapped your head around the
that it's going to be difficult use
these meetings to meet cool people I got
to meet everyone on Sand Hill Road up to
Fortune 500 CEOs and I used every
meeting just as a connection the most
important thing that you can get out of
a fundraising meeting is a connection to
someone because that's not going to be
the first time you run into that person
I have a later one later a piece of
advice that's gonna be about how no one
invests the first time but basically you
should be thinking about this as a
connection for a long period of time
someone who you will be able to ask for
advice if you have a really good
connection with them so just use
fundraising as a way to meet a bunch of
really really great people over the
course of a very long period of time
it's literally like running into a wall
repeatedly for 12 months I getting
rejected 3 or 15 times in two years not
really all that funny
it's literally like I spent the year
just getting rejected and then someone
said yes I was like oh my god thank you
okay I third pitch your company to
everyone this is this this means is so
basically VCS and angel investors love
having prepared entrepreneurs and in
order to be prepared for your angel
investor and VC meetings have your
friends pitch your friends have your
friends ask you questions it turns out
VCS and angels aren't the only ones who
ask good questions actually we probably
ask worst questions than anyone else and
and you can learn about your business
and how people are perceiving your
business and I really think that a lot
of entrepreneurs don't do this before
they get into a meeting with someone
test it and if you're not willing to
actually test your pitch on one of your
friends like you're not going to be
doing well in an angel or VC meeting
that's just it like generally how it
goes if you feel like embarrassed by
your product your I have to pitch boost
every single day you have to be pitching
your business three to ten times every
day in order to really get good at it
and for me
your entire concept okay this is an
unfortunate consequence of fundraising
you have no money until it's in the bank
so I went when I went through the
fundraising process you will meet a lot
of yes-men investors and like you will
get them to say yes in that meeting and
that's fantastic and then like you you
will try to follow up with them and then
they might be late on replying and then
I you know you have a couple emails back
and forth and then all of a sudden like
it's been two months and they're not
going to be wiring you any money and
like that that's very disheartening
because they gave you like it they gave
you that moment where you're like oh man
this person said yes and then they
ripped it away from you which is the
worst feeling in the world so just know
like again this is a part of like
fundraising is difficult but just know
you have no money until it's in the bank
no money is committed and so what this
should do is make you feel once someone
says yes some of our investors actually
I don't necessarily recommend this but
basically what they do is they have
convertible notes of different amounts
in their backpack and they literally
will push it across the table and be
like if someone says yes they're like
how much and and and and and it and like
it but it's it's literally the concept
is there where it's like you have a
ticking time-bomb
of getting that money from their bank
account to your bank account so just
know that it's not nothing until the
money's in the bank yep clicker good it
did for this entrepreneur for the rigger
okay five this is the the one investors
invest in lines not dots the first time
you meet an investor that is the first
time you exist you did not exist
previously for that investor for anyone
in their their minds and so they're
thinking okay so now I want to see this
entrepreneur start a track record this
is day zero for this entrepreneur and so
over the course of time the reason
accelerators like boost YC all these
other accelerators are really good is
that you you have three months investors
trust us and we help companies build a
track record over the course of three
months and so what you wanted so lines
not dots basically I'm stealing this
from a really great entrepreneurs name
is Jeff Siebert I've
to say that at the beginning of the
slide I always want to give credit where
credit's due he's awesome um but
investor investing lines not das
basically just means you need you cannot
think that investors can invest the
first time that you meet them do not
ever think that you it is the first time
that yeah just don't think that so over
the course of time like just keep that
investor update the best entrepreneurs
they email me every month and update me
on what what has gone well and what has
not gone well over the last month that
is all the best entrepreneurs
I literally and they're very consistent
about it and it also if you do a monthly
report basically it gives you an idea of
what happened over the last month for
yourself and you're able to summarize it
for yourself but it's really important
to keep investors updated I'm sort of
running out of time but okay I investors
invest in team traction or hype
so basically team I've referred to
traction is really really important get
your product out there hype it's
something that like I've seen
entrepreneurs do this and it's basically
you convince an investor and all of the
investors friends that you are the
coolest thing at a moment in time and it
is really really difficult to do I do
not recommend trying like going out and
being like I'm gonna raise off of hype I
reckon I mean the best way to do like
the best way to fundraise is to have a
good product and good traction that is
like real traction and yeah so the
that's that okay the seventh point is
have a plan B assume I mean you really
don't want to assume you're not going to
raise money but realistically you might
not you still need if you are truly
setting out to solve a problem in the
world and you really want to make that
difference happen its money should not
be the reason that that difference
doesn't get it happen so you should have
a plan B on cutting costs on making sure
that everything happens the way that you
want it to and yeah so okay here I'm
seeing me through this okay fundraising
is a means to an end so busy
we make sure that wasn't yeah I don't
need to explain it explain if anyone
wants to ask me later
but the fundraising is amusement you
need to grow faster you need to hire
someone you need to get an engineer you
need to there are a lot of things that
you need to do and you need that money
for you should not be thinking that it's
a it's an element of success a lot
there's a there's a weird mentality in
the Silicon Valley right now where if
someone fund raises it makes them feel
that they have been successful it should
not be that is not the mentality that
you need to have you were using that
money as a tool to grow your business
that's one of the most important things
that you should be able to walk away
from this presentation with in addition
to that some of the thinking if you are
in that fundraising process Microsoft
eBay Viva systems collectively raised
eleven million dollars when they were
fundraising and that is now on the
Nasdaq Stock Exchange worth four hundred
twenty billion dollars for market caps
you don't need to raise a lot of money
to make a big impact I I'm an investor
and the best in the best companies don't
raise all that much money it's a really
important thing don't think that
fundraising is the end goal fundraising
is not the angle the end goal is
building make solving the problem you
set out to solve and that's all that's
my presentation hopefully you enjoyed it